[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily unsuspecting
motorists tell a florida jury how a
former deputy allegedly planted drugs in
their vehicles
during traffic stops one woman tears up
as she describes how the false charge
changed her life didn't think i would be
able to beat anything then it was law
enforcement
and i wanted to go home and take care of
my my grandbaby
the tiger on the loose in houston texas
and why a man out on bond for a murder
charge
is back behind bars for fleeing i guess
my client likes tigers
and the judge's ruling paving the way
for derrick sherwin to be sentenced to a
longer term in prison for the murder of
george floyd
plus three defendants charged in the
death of a mod arbory want evidence from
the victim's past shown
to a jury at trial is the body cam
footage of aubrey's run-in with law
enforcement relevant
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a judge in georgia is now considering
whether ahmad arbury's past
encounters with law enforcement should
be allowed into evidence
for the upcoming trial of three
defendants
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael are charged with murdering
aubry
while he was out jogging last february a
third man william rhodey brian is
charged with boxing aubry
in while filming the incident the
defendants claim aubrey was a burglar
running through their neighborhood
prosecutors say the mcmichaels were the
aggressors
and therefore can't claim self-defense
they're scheduled to stand trial
in october now the defense wants the
jury to hear
about aubrey's past criminal incidents
including when aubrey was arrested for
bringing a loaded gun to a high school
basketball game
in 2013.
yeah there was an individual that had
been
observed with a gun was given his
description
and was advised over the radio i learned
over the radio
that he had exited the gym and was
running away
the lieutenant challenged him at the
door and said you know stop i need to
talk to you
and at that point in time he ran out the
door
and ran away from the officer refused to
comply with the officers
command to stop i need to talk to you
ran out the door um and ran away from
multiple officers there
until he got to my position where i
tried to apprehend him as well
okay did any of the officers try to put
their hands on him or to physically
restrain him yes
and what did mr arboret do as a result
of that he resisted he ran
and swapped their hands away and ran
did any of the officers get injured one
of the officers was chasing him and fail
yes
okay but no other physical signs of
injury or scratches or anything like
that no
defense attorneys are also trying to
bring into evidence aubrey's conviction
for shoplifting at a walmart in 2017.
there were four black males who were
confronted by
the loss prevention officer who were
trying to leave the scene as i was
arriving
and what did you understand the nature
of the confrontation was
that the suspect in question was
trying to take out a vizio 65-inch tv
through the grocery side doors
and by suspect in question do you mean
mr aubry yes
do you remember whether or not when you
asked those individuals in particular mr
arbory to
to stop walking if mr aubry stopped
walking
up on your command they they did and he
did
however mr arbory was the only one who
was
vocal about it okay what do you mean by
vocal uh he was a little confrontational
at first he didn't want to do it
he didn't want to comply with sitting
down
but after repeated requests i'm not sure
how many times i told him to sit down if
they finally just did it i guess
that was also when backup officers
started to arrive
and then a third incident defense
attorneys wanted to tell the jury
about a tense confrontation aubry had
with police in 2017.
aubrey was stopped in a park parking lot
and refused to let officers search his
car
he was not arrested
[Music]
so what happened there in your
estimation uh he approached me
thinking i was going to go into his car
which i wasn't going to do
he approached me fast enough to the
point where i actually had to
physically uh push him away from me
and what was the concern that you had at
that moment
the concern at that point was he was
going to assault me
do you feel like his conduct was in fact
assaulted already or not
i think it i think it was to a point but
at
that
point that was the uh clear
that was clear that it was an assaultive
behavior that was
was this the first time somebody had
used profanity with you
that was the first time that somebody
had acted that way with me yes
okay that was what i remember that was
my question is that the first time
someone had used profanity with you i
believe so yes
a year and a half as a patrol officer
and no one had
used profanity with you de-escalations
for tape wine
joining us today is the state attorney
for palm beach county
florida dave ehrenberg and terry austin
dave a major legal battle here that i
see at least is whether or not
self-defense even applies for the
defendant
do you see self-defense here good
evening brian i don't see self-defense
here
these defendants were the initial
aggressors aubry tried to avoid them
they confronted him with a shotgun
and he tried to get away you don't get
to shoot someone
claiming self-defense when the person on
the other side
is trying to escape and may even use
their his fists and so no i don't see
self-defense
as a defense here i don't think that the
court should allow it
yeah that initial aggressive part dave i
think is really the
the clutch part there terry and this
whole business about
bringing up aubry's history especially
telling the police he can't be searched
in a park
and there being no arrest where's the
relevance this just looks like an
attempt
to attack aubrey's character i couldn't
agree with you more here brian there's
no question this looks like a character
assassination
we know that prior bad acts are not
supposed to be used unless they are
showing intent or motive and
all of the acts they just talked about
have nothing to do with what was going
on
here he wasn't trying to steal anything
in fact we have video
of him inside the house they say they
saw him in and he wasn't trying to do
anything and clearly
being caught in a park none of this has
anything to do with
what happened in this incident in this
incident
he was trying to save his life as dave
just said and
you know to your point brian you have to
weigh
the relevance with the prejudicial value
and
of course if anyone is listening to this
they are going to think
to themselves that this is a bad guy and
so it's definitely character
assassination
yeah it's me interesting to see how that
plays out thank you both still ahead on
law and crime daily
houston police are on the prowl as a
search for a missing tiger continues
but first the body cam footage allegedly
showing a former deputy
planting drugs on unsuspecting victims
the compelling testimony
from motorists next
[Music]
we're back a former florida deputies on
trial for allegedly planting drugs on
unsuspecting drivers
prosecutors say the ex-cops body cam
video from one woman's traffic stop is
damning evidence
[Applause]
february 15 2018 teresa odom was pulled
over by then deputy zachary wester
for defective brake lights did it have
some problems with the lights
no sir during the stop wester asked to
search the car
odum complied i knew there was nothing
in my car
after a few minutes of searching wester
came back with this
it is yogurt i know okay
how about this that is not mine no
sir ultima admits the spoon is hers but
says she was using it to eat
yogurt however she says the plastic
baggie and contents inside
are not hers the prosecution says the
video from odom's arrest is one of their
strongest arguments
for a conviction the defense however
says odom is not credible
and you've also you have an attorney and
you've also filed a civil suit out of
this incident correct
yes sir i have was it one crime of
dishonesty you've been convicted of
yes odom is not alone there are over a
dozen
cases similar to hers and for a number
of those western's body cam was off at
the time of the vehicle search
like many others odum entered a plea
deal because i just didn't think i would
be able to beat anything then it was law
enforcement
and i wanted to go home and take care of
my my grandbaby those three months old
here to discuss the trial the alleged
drug planting ex-cop is state attorney
for palm beach county
florida dave aronberg and terry austin
now dave
this video seems to be the strongest for
the prosecution as you saw
there we kind of slowed it down just a
little and some of our viewers were
asking why was the prosecution doing
that in this case but you have an
opinion on that what do you think
yeah you showed the video in its
entirety and at regular speed and then
later you can
slow it down but it doesn't matter i
think if you slow it down
in front of the jury when you have 12 or
more different victims here
i think at some point it's a little
overkill you've got so many victims and
we're all saying the same thing
i think the prosecutors rely on their
testimony as much as they would on the
video
and this case is not going to be won or
lost because
the video was not slowed down i'd agree
there they've got so much there to work
with
they maybe don't want to get lost in the
trees from the forest now
teresa odom broke down when she talked
about how this case affected her life
did her testimony help the prosecution
in the way she delivered it absolutely
no question about it she was an
excellent witness first of all you saw
her in the video and she
adamantly denied having any drugs she
said no sir and she meant that
and then you saw her on the stand she
broke down she was holding
her eyes and trying not to cry it was
really difficult i think the juries
could relate to her helplessness and to
her frustration
and then you know she remembers spent
about three
weeks in jail there's no question that
she should be bringing a civil action
she has damages here
her reputation has been damaged and just
because she had
passed violations doesn't mean that she
isn't telling the truth now
and this is such an abuse authority i
hope that if the evidence shows it and
it looks like it is
that he really serves the time yeah i
think to dave points and also
yours there being such a volume of
victims here
that might be able to cure well you're
getting a civil suit here
you're doing this here well there's 12
of them i don't know how strong that
argument's going to be
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily a cold case connection
how remains from christy crystal creek
might be linked to a serial killer
plus how long will derek sherman spend
in prison
the latest ruling in the murder of
george floyd still ahead
welcome back let's check in on some top
legal stories making headlines at the
law and crime network
the law and crime network is set to be
the only camera in the courtroom when
the highly anticipated murder trial of
robert durst resumes this tuesday
the new york real estate air is accused
of killing his best friend susan berman
in her los angeles home in december
2000. durst trial had three days of
openings and 10 witnesses take the stand
before coven 19 postponed the trial on
march 12
2020. the trial judge has repeatedly
denied motions by the defense to declare
a mistrial
over the 14-month long adjournment the
trial could last up to six months
live capital gavel coverage begins on
may 17th
in georgia prosecutors will seek the
death penalty for the accused atlanta
area spa
shooter if convicted robber long is
charged with going on a shooting spree
that left eight dead and another wounded
at three spots
long was indicted tuesday on a dozen
more charges including hate crimes
and domestic terrorism prosecutors are
now accusing long
of targeting the victims for murder
because of their quote actual or
perceived race
national origin sex and gender
prosecutors say the murders show an
outrageously or wantonly vile
horrible or inhumane depravity of mine
and out of montana the remains from a
1985 cold case may be linked to a serial
killer
janet lee lucas's remains were found
near christie crystal creek
by a bear hunter in 1985. authorities
are looking into wayne nantes
aka the missoula mauler because her
remains were found
near a 1984 cold case which was recently
linked
to nance and now for the latest on brian
ross investigates
let's check in with our chief
investigative correspondent
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
a troubling story about a place once
thought to be one of the most
wonderful summer camps anywhere in the
country but a new lawsuit brought by two
former campers
calls that into question the first time
i was sexually assaulted by a male
counselor
was when i was 13 i was raped the people
who run the camp say they are
investigating
and they deny anyone tried to cover up
any sex crimes
that's this week i'm brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network brian back to you
thanks brian when we come back a big cat
out
is at large in a space city and no we're
not talking about the tiger king
we break down this new tiger tale and
who police are saying
could be facing jail time
[Music]
welcome back a new ruling in the derek
showman case paves the way for the
former minneapolis police officer
to receive a longer sentence
judge peter cahill ruled there were
aggravating factors in the death of
george floyd
according to an order made public on
wednesday cahill found that chauvin
abused the position of trust and
authority when he was trained floyd in
the prone position
and did not render aid when floyd became
unresponsive
cahill further found chauvin treated
floyd with particular cruelty that the
defendant committed the crime as a group
of three or more
and that children were present chauvin
is scheduled to be sentenced on june
25th
he faces up to 40 years in prison
david ehrenberg let's imagine you're
keith ellison the attorney general who
handled this case
you just finished reading this decision
from the judge what's the thought
process going
forward now you're thinking about
getting close to the 40-year max
and remember it was chauvin who decided
to let the judge
decide whether they were aggravating
factors they both
they all have to be shown beyond a
reasonable doubt the judge found that
four of the five
existed so you're gonna ask that same
judge to now sentence
the defendant too close to the maximum
40 years we had a case here of an
officer
killing a black motorist and we asked
for life in prison the judge gave 25
years
so they should ask for 40 years or
somewhere near that
all right that makes a lot of sense
especially because uh terry austin judge
cahill just needed
one factor to depart from the
recommended 150 month jail sentence
but with four factors is children more
likely to get the max as
dave is suggesting i think he's going to
get very
close to the max i mean everyone is
thinking from a legal perspective that
because he's not had any priors he's
probably not going to get the max but
i do think because he's had all of these
other aggravating factors
there's no question that he abused his
trust and his authority he did this in
front of children you know it was
particularly cruel and watching the
video
you could see all of that and everyone
could feel the impact of that
so i do think that it will add
additional months to the sentence i
think probably close to 30 years
and i think the judge made the right
decision i mean basically he said
that chovin wasn't in any sort of
particular circumstances as far
as george floyd was concerned in terms
of the condition of george floyd but he
found
everything else and i think that that's
important i think he
definitely thought that this deserved as
much as he could under the sentencing
guidelines
to give as far a sentence as he could as
maximum as he could and i think that's
exactly what we will see
when the sentencing actually occurs yeah
so maybe a high ask from the prosecution
here
but the judge coming just a little bit
below that somewhere in the 30 35
mark and a lot of people have been
discussing that as well thank you both
for your input
now to texas where the search is on in
houston for a tiger that's been on the
loose for a couple of days
as angina levy tells us the man accused
of owning the tiger says it doesn't
belong to him
victor cuevas is right now behind bars
in fort bend county texas
he's accused of evading arrest for
possessing a tiger
earlier this week people in a houston
neighborhood were absolutely stunned
when a tiger sauntered across the street
a sheriff's deputy held the tiger at bay
you cannot have
a tiger and the city of houston so right
there's a violation
houston police are now looking for the
tiger they say the tiger was living in a
home rented by victor cuevas
and that cuevas took the tiger back to
his house and a man later put the tiger
in a vehicle
and drove away with it so why exactly
did cuevas have a tiger
that is a hundred thousand dollar
question cuevas lawyer says he had plans
for cuevas to surrender to houston
police
but houston officers swooped in and
arrested cuevas anyway for evading
arrest
i got a bad taste in my mouth for
houston police being
you know sneaky and dirty and double
crossing me
when we were trying to help cuevas faces
a murder charge in another county
attorney mike elliott says cuevas acted
in self-defense in that case
he says cuevas doesn't actually own the
tiger whose name is india
bottom line is though the tiger is not
his the tiger belongs to an individual
named deandre
this isn't the first time people have
noticed animals at the house that cuevas
rents
we have reports that he does have
monkeys monkeys are not illegal to have
in the city of houston if they're under
30 pounds
we believe he has two of those victor
cuevas will be back in court in fort
bend county later
this week at that time prosecutors will
ask to revoke his bail in that case
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
thanks anjanet back one last time is
dave ehrenberg and terry austin
dave it doesn't seem like houston's
monkeying around here but as a
prosecutor in florida i'm sure you're no
stranger to exotic animals in your cases
what do you think of the prosecution's
case here they need more evidence to tie
him to the missing tiger
and you know brian when i saw this story
i had to look again
uh to make sure it wasn't in florida it
sort of sounds like a florida story you
sure as this was texas
uh i also had to look at my calendar
because this definitely seemed like a
2020 story it's so bizarre
and when i was reading about this story
i saw carol baskin from tiger king
was featured as like an expert uh just
when you thought the apocalypse wasn't
upon us you see carol baskin as a legal
expert
so yeah i think the uh the prosecution
needs more evidence before they can
charge here besides this guy is
being accused of murder in another
county and that's going to be a much
more serious crime
uh i lastly the fact that carol baskin
was mentioned in all this shows that
there's always a florida connection to
everything
exactly uh great point there terry the
defense is arguing that cuevas
was merely a good samaritan who found
the cat it's not his cat i know
you're a cat lover does the defense make
sense to you
well i wouldn't say i'm a cat lover i
take care of my family pets but
in any event as far as this cat is
concerned interestingly enough you can
own
a dangerous cat in texas you just have
to have
about a hundred thousand dollars in
liability insurance you have to make
sure you register the cat you have to
make sure that you have a cage big
enough to fit the cat and it has to be
in the cage so cuevas could still get in
trouble for having the cat outside
and by the way brian the statute says
that even
if you don't own the cat if you control
and you have custody you could still be
liable so
i think saying that cuevas is not the
owner is not going to get him out of
trouble here
the cat should have been behind a cage
and been
protected obviously from the public and
the public protected from the cat
so i think that he does still face some
exposure here
all right so we got to double check and
make sure this case is not actually in
florida
we i think we can confirm this in texas
and of course those other elements as
well
dave terry thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here at law on crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you